hey guys I'm Brett clothes tech writer
and jumped most sharks and humans I'm
out here in Northern California checking
out the new gopro hero4 session
first off the hero4 session is
waterproof on its own up to 33 feet that
means it doesn't require the same
plastic waterproof housing you need for
the other GoPro cameras you should be
fine for surfing swimming snorkeling
other watersports
other than scuba diving because of that
the session is 50% smaller than the
hero4 silver or black when waterproof
and ready to mount it's also 35% lighter
basically if you've always dreamed of
having a camera so small you can mount
it on your pet mouse today is your lucky
day it's also small enough that we're
probably gonna see it in some very
interesting places and porn yeah you'll
also notice that the session takes a
dramatically different form factor from
any other GoPro of the past this is
perfect little inch and a half cube
whereas all the other GoPros with these
little rectangles this gives the session
some unique advantages for instance you
can drop it into its frame Mountain
pretty much any orientation this means
it's basically the first GoPro you can
side mount to things like a helmet
without using an awkward elbow joint
type mount it comes with two different
frames as well standard and low profile
to test how much drag it had I swam
across a lake with the camera strapped
to my back and then again with it on my
chest I could feel the straps catching a
little water during freestyle but
nothing on the camera itself and during
breaststroke I pretty much forgot it was
there which is impressive GoPro is
really trying to play up the ease of use
with the session and as just two buttons
you press the main button on top turns
the camera on and starts recording hit
it again it stops shooting and turns off
I found that this saved a ton of battery
life and it actually lasted a lot longer
than the hero4 silver I was comparing it
to despite it having a smaller battery
it takes about four seconds to turn on
and start recording which feels like a
very long time when there's a wave
coming if you long press that same
button it'll go into a time-lapse mode
shooting one pic every half second
the other button in the back toggles
Wi-Fi on and off will display the video
mode you've selected and will add a
hilight tag while you're rolling
unfortunately you can't actually change
the settings or the mode on the camera
itself to do that you need to pair it
with your smartphone or a GoPro Wi-Fi
remote control which is sold separately
this kind of sucks as it's not always
practical have those things with you
speaking of modes it can shoot 1080p
video at up to 60 frames per second
1440p at 30 frames a second and 720p at
100 frames per second some of those
modes also support super view which
takes a 4:3 ratio shot and then
compresses it down to a standard 16:9
this gives you a lot more at the top and
the bottom of your frame it's the mode I
use for things like surfing mountain
biking and snowboarding audio tests
one-to-one to high notes low notes audio
tests one-to-one to high notes low notes
so the session has two microphones that
are specially built to help them drain
quickly when they get wet
they actually work pretty well what's
interesting is that the price point is
still pretty high at $400 it cost the
same amount as the hero4 silver which
has more resolutions and frame rates to
choose from as swappable batteries in a
built-in LCD touchscreen which makes it
really easy to use so you're basically
paying for the small form factor here
unfortunately image quality takes a
major hit for that form factor compared
it to the hero4 silver and it's just no
contest take a look at the sharpness
here this is the session and this is the
silver look how much more detail you can
see in the grass in the front the bushes
in the middle and the trees in the back
in the image on the left or check out
the lighting in this scene this is the
session and this is the silver it almost
looks like they were shot on entirely
different days the silver on the left is
far brighter and truer to life than the
session on the right look at the colors
here this is the session this is the
silver session silver the image on the
left has brighter richer more vibrant
colors for low-light the session really
cranks up the gain which produces a
pretty noisy and very read image the
silver on the other hand is a lot
cleaner and a lot more natural-looking
but it's also dark as hell we'll leave
it to you to decide which one you prefer
I also found that water droplets were
far more prone to stick to the lens of
the session
I don't know why that is but I
definitely ended up with way more usable
footage from the silver finally this
shot encapsulate everything I've been
saying about image quality let's pause
it right here
check out that dynamic range despite the
fact that I'm backlit the silver has my
face nicely exposed while the session
loses it in the shadows the sulfur has a
higher bitrate too which gives you more
detail and makes color correcting easier
look at the detail on the bluff behind
me and even up close on my wetsuit and
surf board basically in image quality
the silver blows the session out of the
water by every metric and in my opinion
image quality is king considering
there's no difference in price there's
just no way I'm going to recommend
buying the hero4 session over the hero4
silver if they could pack the same image
quality and usability of the silver into
the form factor of the session they'd
really have a winner
but for now stick to the one that takes
prettier pictures so what do you think
is this the camera you've been waiting
for or are you more likely to go for the
more powerful hero4 silver which cost
the same or the even more beastly hero4
black which cost a hundred bucks more
let us know what you think in the
comments below subscribe to wire it if
you haven't already with all that being
said there's only one thing left to do